hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the chapter
called situation and character in her
work the second sex Simone de Beauvoir
carries out a very interesting analysis
of the position or situation of women in
relation to what we could call the
masculine world of logic rules
principles universals in general and
she's setting out a really penetrating
analysis here of why it is that women
are placed into a dilemma where they
can't fully buy in because they know
that some of this is BS and they also
can't provide some sort of alternative
to escape to so they wind up mired in a
sort of as she's putting at contrariness
or another way she talks about it as
resentment there's a number of different
synonyms that she's going or mortalities
if you prefer that she's going to
discuss and this this entire section
begins where she says woman is bound in
a general way to contest foot by foot
the rule of man though recognizing his
overall supremacy and worshiping his
idols hence that famous contrariness for
which he has often been
approached now why would she be contrary
is it for the sake of being contrary
does she win something in the process no
it's coming out of a sort of reaction
she says having no independent domain
she cannot oppose positive truths and
values of her own to those asserted and
upheld by males she can only deny them
but her denial is not going to be a
complete denial either she says her
negation is more or less thoroughgoing
according to the very to the way respect
and resentiment are proportioned in her
nature but she knows all the faults of
the masculine system and she has no
hesitation in exposing them so in a
certain way women are placed in a
epistemological privileged position when
it comes to recognizing what's missing
where the gaps are in what she's gonna
call masculine logic she goes out and
she says women don't have a grasp on the
world of men because their experience
does not teach them to use logic and
technique inversely masculine apparatus
loses its powers at the frontiers of the
feminine realm now this is a very
important point women's experiences
women's human experiences have typically
been overlooked or denigrated or treated
reductively by men or Mis
misappropriated and you know the wrong
conclusions have been drawn from it
precisely because they're not men's
experiences and so she says that there's
a whole region of human experience which
the male deliberately chooses to ignore
because he fails to think it this
experience women live and because women
live it women can think it that's not to
say that all men are necessarily cast
out of possibly understanding anything
about women and their lives and their
experiences but in general that is in
fact the case I'm
you struck myself by you know I'll admit
that that myself I get pointed out to me
many things that I don't understand but
I'm often amazed at my male colleagues
how little they seem to understand of
things particularly those who claim to
to be you know allies or feminists be
that as it may
let's look now at this dilemma that that
she poses she tells us that the
experience of the man is intelligible
but interrupted by blanks the end of the
woman is within its own limits
mysterious and obscure not complete
there's something not lacking there but
something that's overlooked and so she
goes on and she says it's understandable
in this perspective woman takes
exception to masculine logic why because
logic doesn't actually apply to as much
as its pretensions are which is to apply
to everything logic claims to be
universal principles claim to be
universal covering every instance but it
doesn't really work that way she says so
she says well why is this there's
there's really a dilemma that that the
woman is placed within she can either
agree to masculine logic principles the
way of the world however you want to
frame it but if she does agree to it
then she's selling herself out why
because to begin with the masculine
logic is not actually applicable to her
experience it's not the way that the
world works in the portion that she's
living in and reflecting upon and
shoehorning it into the categories of
mask and logic is not going to be
particularly helpful it's also a problem
because like she says masculine
reasoning becomes an underhand form of
force men's undebatable pronouncements
are intended to confuse her she's
alienated she's stuck within a framework
that she's forced to then accept what's
the alternative what's the other horn of
the dilemma well refuse it but that's
not really a live possibility either
unfortunately you can reject the entire
system she says but what is she going to
do in that case de Beauvoir says she
lacks the means to reconstruct society
in different form so it's kind of a
damned if you do and a damned if you
don't situation and one way of getting
through a dilemma instead of just simply
grasping the horns is to go through the
horns of the dilemma and this is what
she says that many women in fact do so
this is where a lot of accusations of
duplicity arise she says she does not
accept it as it is halfway between
revolt and slavery she resigns herself
reluctantly too masculine authority on
each occasion he has to force her to
accept the consequences of her
half-hearted yielding man pursues that
Tamara a companion half slave half free
in yielding to him he would have her
yield all the convincing this of the an
argument but she knows that he has
himself chosen the premises on which his
rigorous deductions depend as long as
she avoids questioning then then he will
easily reduce her to silence but he
won't convince her because she senses
his arbitrariness so this is a third
alternative to say fine I'll go along
with your nonsense which to you doesn't
appear to be nonsense but I'm not going
to call it not nonsense I'm going to
treat it as it is and I'll give you
ground but you're gonna have to pull me
along and you know this is what leads to
so many arguments between people taking
this masculine and feminine side saying
but I thought you agreed to this well
yes but I understand it in a different
way and interestingly this is part of
what it means to be a free subject
be able to reinterpret those who had
bind us to absolutely fixed principles
you know you agreed to this and this
this and this and this they they often
don't realize how arbitrary those are
and how it stands in the way of them
achieving what it is that they're
looking for in the other person so
that's one way out of the dilemma and
she talks about women experiencing
ambiguity
she says woman does not entertain the
positive belief that truth is something
other than men claims she recognizes
rather that there isn't any fixed truth
it's not only the changing nature of
life that makes her suspicious of the
principle of constant identity nor is it
the magic phenomenon with which he's
surrounded that destroy the notion of
causality it is at the heart of the
masculine world itself it is in herself
as belonging to this world that she
comes up on the ambiguity of all
principle of all value of all that
exists what do we mean by ambiguity here
and the guity means that it's subject to
interpretation because it can be
understood or experienced or approached
or dealt with in multiple ways an
ambiguous term is a word that means
multiple things like seal it can mean
the pop singer it can mean the animal it
can mean the thing that I'm doing to
close off a meal there used to be a
thing called the seal Emile he used to
own
that's ambiguity and so the settled
rules the absolutely fixed principles
they are also ambiguous and I want to
reiterate this point she says she finds
at the heart of the masculine world
itself whether men recognize it or not
and in herself is belonging to this
world she comes upon this ambiguity of
all principal value of everything that
exists and she knows as de Beauvoir says
that masculine morality as it concerns
her is a hoax what does that mean well
she goes on to explain men thunders hit
forth his code of virtue and honor
but in secret he invites her to disobey
it so you know prime example of this as
she talked about is women should be pure
but you should be a [ __ ] for me in the
bedroom you should you know everybody
should follow these fixed laws of
morality but in my case and it you know
with you will violate the rules and
women see this over and over and over
again she actually uses that great line
before about the you know valet and the
hero she a little bit later she says she
has the same cynicism because she sees
man from top to toe as a valet sees his
master right women see that men over and
over again are making demands that they
don't saw that themselves live up to
that they're being hypocrites that
they're being duplicitous and at the
same time women suffer the burdens of
this most of the time unless they happen
to be lucky so you know she she says
that women view this masculine morality
as a hoax there's another thing that
this leads to which is not a
particularly good thing de Beauvoir is
not actually praising this as something
that all of us should embrace but she
talks about women here we go
not accepting logical principles and
moral imperative skeptical about the
laws of nature
woman lacks the sense of the universal
to her the world seems a confused
conglomeration of special cases so you
know what what does this lead to
making exceptions in each case she says
regarding benefits she imagines that an
exception will be made in this in my
case she expects special favors the
storekeeper will give her a discount the
policeman will let her through without a
past she's been taught to overestimate
the value of her smile and no one has
told her that all women smile and she
says this shows why women don't succeed
in building at the solid counter
universe whence they can challenge the
male's now and then they rail at men in
general they tell what happens in the
bedroom or a childbirth exchange
horoscopes and beauty secrets but they
lack the
necessary to build this grievance world
the resentments called for their
attitude towards men is too ambivalent
meaning that it's not just an ambiguity
within the masculine world it's also
interjected into women and I want to
close on something that she points out
about this she tells us that none of
women's traits manifest an originally
perverted essence or will they reflect a
situation there's dissimulation
everywhere under a coercive regime she
says quoting for a year and so as long
as there are these male-dominated
structures of society which go on to
form subjects who live according to a
certain psychology depending upon this
and as long as this conflict is going on
this is going to be an ever-present
problem women won't get what they want
men won't get what they want either so
this is a diagnosis on her part but
again she's saying that it's the
structure of society and the subjects
within it that is inducing this
you